[Music]
we're kicking off presidents week here
on the Rubin report and partnership with
learn liberty and we're talking about
five different presidents in five
different days with five different
academics and joining me today is a
professor of history at the United
States Military Academy at West Point
Rob McDonald Rob welcome to the Reuben
report thanks Dave it's great to be here
I'm very excited to talk to you I'm glad
we're kicking off presidents week with
you because we're gonna talk about the
man that you have written this book
about and edited several other books
about Thomas Jefferson everyone knows my
feelings about Thomas Jefferson this is
this is my favorite founder I think this
is the person whose politics have sort
of affected me personally the most so
let's let's just dive right in so let's
just you know so I really want to do
some one-on-one stuff and then I want to
extrapolate on sure on his greater
political philosophies and things in
later life and all that tell me a little
bit just about childhood first let's
just go into some history well you know
Jefferson was born and what was
essentially the edge of civilization in
1743 in the Piedmont of Virginia
his father was kind of an interesting
guy's name is Peter Jefferson he was
sort of a planner you know sort of an
aristocrat but also kind of a pioneer
and with a William and Mary math
professor named Joshua fry Peter
Jefferson plotted this map that would
serve is the kind of signature map of
Virginia for a good 100 years so you
know he was out there in the wilderness
and Native Americans would come through
Jefferson's house and you know travel
with his dad to Williamsburg where his
father was a member of the House of
Burgesses so were they actually
surveyors so they were doing sort of
what Washington did as well and really
looking at the land and parceling out
where houses were gonna be where roads
were gonna be mainly what they're do is
they were plotting the boundary line
between Virginia and North Carolina you
know so there was sort of an agreed-upon
location of it but they were putting
that within the context of the actual
you know natural topography gotcha so
what else do we need to know about his
childhood specifically its siblings
anything we know about his education
anything like well I mean you know
Jeffers
has a first memory and I guess we all
have first memories in his first memory
I think is especially poignant and maybe
relevant to what I predict will come up
in the rest of our discussion when he
was three years old his family was
moving temporarily from near
Charlottesville to a house of a relative
and the James River between the
Williamsburg in Richmond and Jefferson
was being carried on a pillow looking up
into the face of an enslaved man so I
mean this is a the world edged into his
mind and this result this is the world
into which he is born Wow that that is
incredible
what about education-wise do we do we
know anything about high school you know
just the later before before the
politics yeah so you know he had a
number of different teachers when he was
at this this house this family house
that they moved to called Tuckahoe
he had essentially a grammar school
teacher later on he had a teacher who
focused on Greek and Latin and then you
know in his late teens he moved to
Williamsburg and became a student at the
College of William and Mary and it was
kind of a an interesting time to be in
Williamsburg
you know when Jefferson was reading for
the law he was I believe 21 years old
and you know he heard Patrick Henry in
the House of Burgesses I'm talking about
the Stamp Act you know and he and he
said essentially you know Caesar had as
Brutus referring to King George the 3rd
and you know people shouted treason
treason and this is when Henry said if
this is treason make the most of it yeah
and you know here's young Jefferson kind
of hanging in the doorway listening in
and you know clear of those years were
formative for yeah are there any other
formative moments like that that kind of
set up his political beliefs um it's
interesting I mean that's a good
question I don't know I mean his his
beliefs are being formed in part by all
the different books that he reads and I
mean there a lot it was a vociferous
reader I mean when I went to Monticello
which we'll talk about yet I mean they
talked about all his library and he was
inventing things I mean this guy loved
knowledge he sure did so much that he
had
the largest library in the Western
Hemisphere Wow I mean that's pretty
incredible
is that you know at the house in
Monticello is that it well he had
several different libraries over the
course of his life you know it's a shame
one of the things that we don't know
about his childhood is exactly you know
what he was reading as a youngster we
have a list of books that his father
owned his father unfortunately died when
Jefferson was about 13 years old so we
have an inventory of his estate but you
know Jefferson's family house burned in
the 1770s
and you know he lost essentially his
first library so there are a few
questions about you know his early
intellectual development but you know
over the course of his life he owned a
number of different libraries including
the one that he would sell to the
Library of Congress after the British
you know burned down the Capitol they
needed new books and you know the books
that he supplied you know increased
their their collection tremendously I'm
always fascinated by that particularly
because it's like did these people learn
their political philosophies by reading
or that they were alive during the
founding of the country they knew why we
came here right you know and and that
it's always just sort of built into them
what freedom is and I suspect it's
probably a little bit of both I think
you're right I mean you know Jefferson's
law professor was this incredibly
significant guy named George width and
you know he trained a generation of
Juris through his perch at the College
of William and Mary and George Wythe
introduced Jefferson to a ruthie kind of
elite circle Jefferson you know played
the violin and the the governor at the
time when Jefferson was were a student
the royal governor in Williamsburg would
have these dinners slash jam sessions
guns you know young Thomas Jefferson
would be included and you could just
sort of imagine the kind of
conversations that he was you know party
to yeah and you know it was it was a
kind of formative moment not only for
him but also for the country that would
become the United States do we know
about any of his other big influences at
the time as far as individuals yeah just
people that he was around
anyone else that maybe flew under the
radar yeah I mean you know he had a
really good friend named Dabney Carr I
think their friendship was was you know
pretty pretty typical for the time they
when they were boys would would run up
this mountain that was near Jefferson's
childhood home and they would hang out
there under this this oak tree and they
made a pledge to each other that the
first one to die would be buried by the
survivor under that tree and that
mountain that they were you know hiking
up became Monticello Wow where jefferson
built his home and when car
unfortunately passed away jefferson made
good on his promise and that's the basis
for the the Monticello cemetery wow
that's interesting I didn't know that
yeah I must have seen it and or maybe
it's part of the tour yeah well I'd it's
at the end of the tour so uh it's a
quick walk yeah
but definitely worth seeing and you know
I mean that cemetery includes people who
have passed away
you know since Jefferson's life but it
includes you know many of the most
important people in his life including
his his wife you know his wife and he
married and I believe 1769
and they you know had many children
together including a few who didn't
survive infancy we know also that she
had some some miscarriages and
eventually she would die of
complications of from childbirth you
know before he hit age 40 so she's
buried there as well and that out she
has a big influence on him so what do we
know about his political philosophy
around the founding time yeah I mean he
Jefferson wrote that in some ways the
most elemental books of public right
were John Locke's two treatises on
government he thought very highly of
Montesquieu he felt very highly of
Shaftesbury so essentially you know he
he was imbibing these works of people
who we could probably call classical
liberals um you know John Locke had a
that's where I was trying to get you to
go yeah well I was hoping you were gonna
say you know I think it's it's a point
that people would agree on I mean you
know John Locke has this unenviable task
to explain to the British people why the
Glorious Revolution of 1688 was was okay
why is it legitimate to overturn one
monarch and bring in new ones like
William and Mary and essentially you
said you know in the state of nature all
people have have rights they pre exist
government you know you have the right
to life and liberty and property problem
in the state of nature is you don't
necessarily have security and so people
band together with others to
reciprocally protect their rights and
that's the origin of government that's
what government is for to protect
individual rights and if government you
know should cease protecting individual
rights or worse right if government
should trample upon those rights people
have the obligation to first petition
right and in complain but if the
government continues a long train of
abuses and usurpations right then they
have you know the obligation to rise up
and have a revolution and establish a
government that does the job that
government is supposed to do yeah and so
it's interesting because he was writing
about that at the same time he was also
building the institutions that have
given us so much freedom I mentioned
right before we started I mean the the
Jefferson Memorial which is a little off
the beaten path so people don't go to it
as much as they go to the Washington
mind him in or the Lincoln Trail or
whatever else but I was just there a few
months ago and you know it's it's a
circular building and they have these
giant plaques with some of his writing
and it's like man this guy his
understanding of what freedom is what
tolerances tolerance in the dry sense
his understand you know he's writing
about God but also at the same time
talking about why we desperately need a
separation of church and state yeah he's
he's writing about as later in life he
was writing laws to help free the slaves
while he owned slaves I think all of
those reasons are why he affected me so
much because it's like he was a complex
man of his time really grappling with
with really hard issues and wasn't a
perfect human while doing it yeah he
wasn't um and and I'm sure that will
come up but you know I think in some
ways one of his most interesting
monuments is the one he designed for
himself his gravestone and you know in
the spring of the final year
his life he designed it you know he
wanted it to be an obelisk and he
brought his epitaph and he wanted it to
read you know here was Barry Thomas
Jefferson author of the American
Declaration of Independence father of
the Virginia statute for religious
freedom and and father of the University
of Virginia and it's amazing when you
think about all right let me think about
what he didn't put on it Yeah right
he didn't he didn't mention I was a
member of the House of Burgesses he
didn't mention that he was remember the
Continental Congress there's a member of
Congress under the Articles of
Confederation didn't mention that he was
our ambassador to France
our first Secretary of State our second
vice president our third president yeah
he mentions instead that he's cutting of
the of the resume well it is been but
think about what it means right I mean
if he focuses on the Declaration right
which gives us political freedom and he
focuses on the Virginia statute for
religious freedom and in the University
of Virginia I mean you know the body and
the mind and the spirit and I think what
he was trying to tell us is that as far
as he was concerned his greatness came
not from the power that people gave to
him right but by them happen but from
the power that he restored to people
yeah I love that I mean that that sums
it up right there this may sound like
this sort of a mature question but do we
know how much work everyone was doing
together on the Declaration of
Independence actually um you know he
does it's probably fair to say that
Jefferson writes 95 percent of the words
that appear in the final text there were
there were some changes that we know
were made by by John Adams for example
in Jefferson's one of his early drafts
instead of writing we hold these truths
to be self-evident
he had it as sacred and undeniable you
know the exact same what's the nature of
the change there because those don't
sound - at odds with each other I don't
think they're at odds with each other at
all I think I think that in some ways
the Declaration is I mean this this
won't be a very satisfying answer for
people but I think that some changes in
the Declaration were made because they
sounded better and you know not to get
too much you got to sell this they've
already do what you do and you know so
there's this late scholar it's Dan
her name Jeff legally wrote a book
called declaring independence and he
made this pretty cool discovery so there
is an early engraving a printing of the
Declaration of Independence that has all
these strange punctuation marks littered
through it and you know five seen this
thing and for the longest time I thought
what's up with this and it turns out
that Jefferson in his library had a book
on rhetoric and it essentially said that
there is this natural like human ear
like people hear things in a way that
they find compelling and there are
certain rhythms certain patterns certain
ways to emphasize words that helps make
ideas more compelling and he suggested
that when people wrote speeches or you
know arguments they should use a system
of abbreviations and symbols to
demonstrate ok here is where you pause
here is where you add F emphasis to take
note of the rhythm and these symbols
correspond to these strange punctuation
marks that appear on this engraving in
other words it's as if Jefferson had and
early drafted the Declaration that we've
never seen yeah because it was passed
along to this printer and and so why did
Jefferson go with life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness instead of you know
the classic Lockean formulation of life
liberty and property yeah I think in
part because it just says better flow so
I wanted to ask you specifically about
that like life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
okay so life were here okay liberty our
freedom the pursuit of happiness yeah is
one of the most to me it's like the most
incredible phrase you could possibly put
in a founding document I think maybe
only one other country is there one
other country that is pursuit of
happiness do you know I'm not sure if
yeah I think one other country and I'm
blanking on who it is has something to
that effect but it's such an empowering
statement to put in there because it's
really saying it's on you people like
well you know we'll protect your life
you know will protect your Liberty but
pursuit of happiness get going sure it's
fascinating
absolutely yeah I mean I think the
Declaration of Independence just
deserves its reputation as this world
historical document and it kind of sums
up a philosophy of freedom I mean just
think about you know the sentence from
what
that that quote is taken you know we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that
they're endowed by their creator not the
government with certain inalienable
rights that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness and then
here's the part the quote often ends
there but the sentence continues that to
secure these rights governments are
instituted among men deriving their just
powers from the consent of the governed
so there's kind of a twin test of
legitimacy as far as governments are
concerned first they have to protect
individual rights that's their goal
right but the means by which they
achieve that goal you know need to be
democratic there's so much there so
let's let's unpack all of it so endowed
by their creator was there any debate
with them on whether that needed to be
in there or because they it would seem
like they all basically there was a
belief in God I think sure by most of
them at least I don't know that were any
of them known to be atheists I don't
think anyone was known to be a theist
but there was definitely a spectrum of
belief well you know so but that's that
phrase is interesting because they
purposely put that in there to say that
something you own something yourself
before government which is really
interesting and yet at the same time he
Jefferson especially was so clear about
the separation between church and state
right which is really kind of
fascinating well I mean the church is
too important to be contaminated by the
state right I mean you know in the
church when you think about it what was
that really the view or was it that he
didn't want the church infecting that I
think it was both it was both
it was absolutely both I mean you know
what absolute power corrupts absolutely
when you think about the Dark Ages right
I mean you have tremendous collusion
between the church and the government
the King receives his legitimacy from
from the Pope right and in turn the king
would require everyone to support the
church and you know if you went against
the state you were going against God and
when you went to the when you went to
your execution as punishment there was
not only a government you know
executioner but there was a priest
standing next to him to tell you that
you were gonna go to hell I mean this is
an incredibly powerful combination and I
think
- powerful yeah and I think a lot of
people don't really know that because
even for myself in a pretty well-versed
in this stuff I'm watching the crown on
Netflix and our - yeah and I didn't
realize how intertwined the monarchy was
Ronnie Church I guess I I guess I should
have known but it really was and that
was part of what they were trying to
protect against sure and and so I mean
when Jefferson is thinking about all
right so that's a wonderful moment for
reform we have declared our independence
we have a blank slate and you know how
can we make it so that we actually have
a fighting chance of surviving as a
self-governing people you know getting
these institutional arrangements right
it's really important and you know it
wasn't an easy sell for Jefferson and
James Madison who was his indispensable
partner in this effort to get Virginia
to disestablish you know the Anglican or
the Episcopal Church as a state Church
and partly because some people said and
you can sort of see their point
hey this is a dicey experiment yeah I
know we've we've endeavoured on and if
we're gonna survive as a nation of free
and responsible people or a you know a
state of free and responsible people
don't we need to be moral
you know don't we need to have a basic
understanding of how we should treat
each other and and you know that we
should deal honestly with each other
that we shouldn't steal from one another
isn't religion a good means to impart
those beliefs to the people but you know
Jefferson and Madison there their belief
instead was that actually if if you had
a free marketplace of religion mm-hmm
then people would really be able to
flourish in their beliefs any and you
get the sense that that's really what
happens yeah Virginia Virginia is the
first state in 1786 I think it's 1832 or
1833 that Massachusetts is the last to
disestablish its church but you know
there's a Great Awakening going on
during this time and you see a great
deal of religious innovation and
enthusiasm yeah do we know anything else
specifically about his religious beliefs
or where he sort of was on that spectrum
yeah I mean so Jefferson and you have to
listen carefully
the words Jefferson once wrote in a
letter to a friend of his name Benjamin
Rush that he was a Christian that's a
word that he just used to describe
himself but then he qualified it in that
he was a follower of the philosophies of
Jesus whom he considered to be the
greatest man who ever lived who he
believed had every human excellence and
never claimed anything else
in other words Jefferson called himself
a Christian because he accepted Jesus's
principles his philosophies his
teachings but he denied the divinity of
Jesus so I think by most standard you
know definitions of Christianity he he
wouldn't be included within that circle
we would call him a deist right yes I
believed in God but but but thought that
essentially he created the world he
created the universe and kind of left to
man up to his own devices yeah do we
know anything else about his sort of
internal thoughts just in the days or
weeks leading up to finally you know
presenting the Declaration of
Independence like was he having any
worries was he going man this we might
be biting off a little more than we can
chew here was there any concern yeah you
know he rented this apartment not far
from Independence Hall called the Graf
house and you know he had a couple of
rooms in the second floor and he had
this sort of you know eighteenth-century
laptop it was this lap desk you know
that held his parchment and his ink and
his quill and she was not like his desk
but he had him at the trailer because
he's got that really cool desk that he
invented himself didn't me yeah well he
has a book the revolving book standard
yeah cello it's similar right I mean the
same sort of thing and and you know he's
using this traveling desk to write out
ideas that he and others have basically
internalized he's not referring he says
he's not referring to any like text he
doesn't have a whole lot of books with
him and he's not even really trying to
lay down any principles or any ideas
that people didn't already agree upon
for him he said the Declaration was
supposed to be an expression of the
American mind right he was supposed to
be a statement of consensus that would
bring people together or
the cause of Independence all right so
we declare independence what's it like
the next day do we have any idea what
happened the day after like we you know
what was he doing yeah well I mean what
was Jefferson doing yeah you know
Jefferson continued on for a while as a
member of the Continental Congress but I
think that he and you know his his great
partner in the enterprise of
Independence John Adams I think both of
them shared the sense that now that
independence is achieved the important
work is elsewhere the important work is
not in Philadelphia the important work
is is in William Williamsburg the
important work is in Boston it's in the
the capitals of these 13 new United
States where we have the opportunity to
come up with new constitutions and
reform the laws and essentially you know
purge ourselves of monarchy and become
you know this nation of 13 real
Republic's yeah so what was actually his
first job in government then after that
so we went back to Virginia he was a
member of the legislature he assumed
thereafter became the governor of
Virginia he served two two terms he he
looked at reforming the laws some of his
reforms were were successful others were
unsuccessful
you know Jefferson did not have a great
win-loss record as far as his legal
proposals were concerned interesting the
first bill that he co-sponsored as a
member of the House of Burgesses you
know in 1769 was a bill that would have
made it legal for Virginians to
voluntarily free their slaves and that
measure was voted down and and Jefferson
and his partner in that enterprise were
sort of shouted down as enemies of of
you know the colony yeah do you know
roughly what year that was that was in
1769 say okay 1779 so so let's talk
about his his feelings about slavery
sure and everything else I mean what
when when I've talked about this on the
show I say that as I said you earlier he
was a complex man of his time he owned
slaves while he was writing rights to
free slaves you know they address at
Monticello that he probably had
relations with at least one slave
possibly or is that cleaner I how do we
know anything specifically I don't think
anyone so the
the woman's name is Sally Hemings yeah
and it appears you know it's not 100%
slam-dunk but the evidence adds up to
the strong probability that Jefferson
and and Sally Hemings who was his late
wife's half-sister had a multi-decade
monogamous relationship that yielded a
number of children so I mean they're
just in that description there's there's
a lot to unpack I mean she was she was
the half-sister of his late wife I mean
you know this is the slave slate for
Virginia family trees were oftentimes
tangled vines and you know Jefferson's
father-in-law was the father of this
enslaved woman Sally Hemings Wow and
when Jefferson's wife passed away you
know according to family accounts on her
deathbed she made Jefferson promise that
he would never remarry in part because
her mother had passed away and her
father remarried and it seems as if she
you know never really felt as if she was
regarded in the same way as her new
stepsisters and she didn't want that to
happen to her own daughters so Jefferson
made this promise and a couple years
later he's in France with his daughters
and he sends for the youngest of his
daughter to join them in Virginia join
them in France from Virginia and he by
name requested this elderly
african-american woman to accompany his
youngest daughter but she was sick so
his family back in Virginia instead sent
Sally Hemings to serve as a babysitter
so you know after her arrival at some
point maybe in France probably in France
their relationship began and you know
here's this this woman who probably
resembles Jefferson's wife Sally Hemings
is 3/4 white she is you know from home
right she represents family she
represents Virginia but she's also this
this rare thing she's you know a young
Virginian who's with them in Paris this
is an incredible metropolis there aren't
many white women in Verte
who have seen what Sally Hemings a scene
who speaks some French who've
experienced this important part of his
life with him and and and so and he
can't legally marry her right he he
can't violate his wife's promise with
Sally Hemings because by law yeah you
know she could never become his wife
god there's so much there all right so
obviously we're gonna sort of bounce in
and out of sure a slavery discussion
there but so France was he the
ambassador at the time was that yeah he
was I think so I mean you know so he
went over there initially he was
Benjamin Franklin's understudy and then
when Benjamin Franklin left France
Jefferson was elevated to serve as our
ambassador there this weird term for
back then he was our Minister
Plenipotentiary
really yeah that's a that is very I know
that is very fancy yeah so give me just
the the line from working in the
legislature in Virginia to then becoming
president just so we get that sort of
piece out so uh you know he is the
governor of Virginia
he then agrees to serve as one of
Virginia's representatives in Congress
under the Articles of Confederation it's
at this point in 1784 that Jefferson
proposes a law the ordinance of 1785
that is going to regulate all this
territory that has been recognized as
part of the United States as a result of
the Treaty of Paris which ends the war
for independence
so all this territory from the Great
Lakes down to the Gulf of Mexico between
the Appalachian Zinn the Mississippi
River is now part of the United States
and one of Jefferson's proposals is that
slavery should not be allowed in any of
this territory and I mean wasn't what an
amazing proposal when you think about it
because had it passed the future states
of Kentucky and Tennessee and Alabama
and Mississippi and presumably Louisiana
and Missouri and Texas right would not
have been slave states yeah and it fails
by just one vote now again at that time
he owned slaves he did and this is why I
think it's so interesting and how we're
all just people of our time do we know
anything about his inner thinking about
that like like I think there's a certain
amount of people and I've talked about
this would be a little wider
just freed slaves then yeah you know why
didn't you just let them go so for a
while if he really felt that abolition
that was the way to go for a while away
what wasn't something that was legally
doable I mean again as a result of the
failure of that first public act the the
act to allow for the valent area man so
legally so for a while he legally
couldn't free them yeah
and then you know by the time it was
illegal for Jefferson to free them you
could make the argument that technically
he didn't even really own them
Jefferson inherited from his late
father-in-law not only a large number of
enslaved people including Sally Hemings
right and her family but also a
tremendous amount of debt and you know
that debt essentially just snowballed
over the course of his life he also
cosines alone with the governor of
Virginia who passed away so then
Jefferson was on the hook for about
twenty thousand dollars of debt he was
also let's be fair he was a high-roller
I mean you know the the largest library
in the Western Hemisphere doesn't come
cheap and you know he liked his
furniture and his art and his wine and
by the time Jefferson died he was I
think about a hundred and five thousand
dollars in debt which in today's Maya is
you know between like one and two
million dollars right and so his slaves
really were owned by his creditors and
you know I don't mean to say that to get
him off the hook but I think it's
important to realize too that Jefferson
and the issue of slavery are never going
to be the only issue right that he's
trying to tackle and when you get past
the 1780s and you know to go back to the
trajectory of his life after he's done
in France he's summoned by Washington to
come back to the nation's capital and
serve as our first Secretary of State
and we know that in the 1790s you know
Jefferson is very quickly gonna get
embroiled in disagreements with you know
his colleague Secretary of Treasury
Alexander Hamilton and Jefferson
essentially views the Constitution in a
in a specific sort of way he thinks that
if the Constitution you know gives the
national
a specific power then it has that power
but you know if it doesn't specifically
receive that power in the text of the
Constitution he thinks that you know the
power should remain in the hands of the
states or the people and Hamilton
clearly has a different vision yeah so
so in our lens of 2018 he really was a
constitutional conservative right yeah
he really believed if it's in that text
right that's the power that's delineated
but nothing else Hamilton felt you can
sort of extrapolate yeah I mean a
Moulton thought that you know if
something could be deemed necessary and
proper and Hamilton you know has a point
too because remember the Constitution it
wasn't created to make the government
weaker right I mean it was it was a
victory for nationalists and
centralizers relative to the Articles of
Confederation and Jefferson was part of
that I mean he wanted this new
constitution to be ratified as did James
Madison his chief political ally in the
1790s but they thought that Hamilton was
taking it too far
and that if this Constitution was going
to mean anything right it had to mean
what it actually said yeah and and and
so this struggle right between Jefferson
and Hamilton is in some ways
regionalised
and Hamilton supporters are chiefly in
the north and Jefferson supporters are
chiefly in the south and you know I
don't think it's a surprise that once
you get into the 1790s by and large
Jefferson's actions against the
institution of slavery begin to get
muted right because he needs to win this
this battle to preserve the Liberty of
the new United States and he really
thinks that's what's at stake and he
thinks that Hamilton is essentially this
crypto monarchist right there he's gonna
ban that he's a counter-revolution right
right I mean if we're gonna preserve the
liberty of white Americans that that we
can't then rock the boat on the issue of
slavery and undermine right this
coalition that he and Madison have
created which has its basis in the
American South so I mean it's it's a
it's a difficult compromise yeah was
that the only thing that they really
butted heads on or was it was it like
was it really a broader Jefferson and
Hamilton
or it sounds like you probably had a lot
I think you know so I mean to carry the
story forward a little bit more you know
one of the things that they could agree
upon was that George Washington was
really indispensable to this this bold
experiment with this New Republic right
everybody in America respected George
Washington I mean it's really not an
exaggeration to say that yeah I don't
even feel the need to qualify it I mean
though I just was at Mount Vernon at the
war and he was like guys I'm done which
is incredibly no I mean because again
the the greatest achievement of
Washington is not that he had power
right it said he gave it up yeah and he
gave it up twice he gave it up at the
end of the war for independence and he
would end up giving it up after serving
two terms as president and young people
don't know that actually then yeah I
didn't have to he could have run again
there were many laws about that these
presents were perpetually reelect about
but think about it if Washington had run
for a third term he certainly would have
been elected and the precedent that he
would have established right instead of
the president stepping down after two
terms he would have established the
precedent that the president dies in
office because Washington died in
December of 1799 hmm so so anyway the
fact that Washington's out of the
picture in a way you know lays bared to
America the the emergence of what
essentially would become these two
political parties and they're not like
modern parties but they're clear
alliances you've got the Federalists of
Hamilton's side you've got the
Jeffersonian Republicans and in the
election of 1796 Jefferson and John
Adams are put forth as the two
candidates it's a close election it's a
heated election it's a down-and-dirty
election I mean people say terrible
things yeah like what kind of stuff I
I've tried to ask this yeah well I mean
you know because everyone says
everything's always worse now because of
Twitter but they were saying some pretty
rough stuff about it they were saying
some really rough stuff you know uh I
think one of the famous one of my
favorite people to emerge in the past
year really like in a big way
is the NYU social scientist
I had a mother shadow I've seen the
interview and yeah no I mean great work
I really admire what he's doing because
he's looking at how polarized we have
become and he's laid out a few different
explanations for why that is and and one
of the things that he points to is you
know the press the media is becoming
increasingly partisan and we're losing
kind of the the notion of journalistic
even-handedness and objectivity that
maybe during the the middle of the 20th
century was was born so we have Fox we
have MSNBC well in Jefferson's time that
that was all you had there was no media
objectivity a newspaper was either
Federalists
or it was Republican there was no
attempt to be even-handed and newspapers
didn't even really have much news you
know there might be hearsay that was
reported but essentially they were ads
and op-eds
and if you subscribe to a Jeffersonian
newspaper The Gazette of the the United
States was a federalist newspaper
everything in it would be Pro Federalist
anti Jeffersonian the National Gazette
was the Jeffersonian newspaper
everything in it you know was Pro
Jefferson pro-republican against
Hamilton and against the Federalist so
really controlling the papers in a lot
of ways was more important than
controlling the politicians because that
was the only way you could get the
politicians elected sure although I
think you can make the argument that the
politicians had a great deal of control
and influence over the papers sure you
know they were funding them they were
sometimes with government money you know
so Hamilton gave you know
Treasury Department printing contracts
to John Fenno who was the editor of The
Gazette of the United States and Thomas
Jefferson gave a job in the State
Department as a translator to Philip for
know who was the editor of the National
Gazette so in a way you know both of
these figures are subsidizing right um
now people are kisses by ambassadorships
too right nobody goes to so one other
thing before we get to his presidency
specifically you mentioned the
Republicans and the Federalists I think
I have a sense of what the real
differences were because you've sort of
laid it out with Hamilton's differences
with Jefferson yeah what else we have to
know about those parties like what did
actually look like yeah well this gets
back to a point that that John height
makes right so another thing that he
says exacerbates our current state of
polarization is that ever since the
collapse of the Soviet Union we don't
really have a common agree upon
agreed-upon enemy hmm
in the 1790s the Federalists and the
Republicans they couldn't agree upon an
enemy either right for the Federalists
the enemy was revolutionary France
mm-hmm and for the Republicans the enemy
was was Great Britain right their old
enemy from the the war for independence
and and so you know there's this belief
that if Jefferson gets elected America
is going to endure its own reign of
terror and that he is a French Jacobin
and a radical
the the president of Yale you know
academia didn't I don't know if it ever
had a golden age but it certainly it was
hyper partisan back then as well so the
president of Yale at the time Timothy
Dwight said that if Jefferson got
elected if Republicans should take power
our children will be wheedled or
terrified into singing heretical hymns
the Bible will be cast into a bonfire
right and all of our wives and daughters
will be made victims of legal
prostitution well I mean when you really
think about what you know about
Jefferson oh that's so incredible
because again he didn't have yeah he
didn't have a specific issue with
religion he was just saying we wanted a
separation right there incredible the
way they could twist that well and in a
way I mean the the hyper partisanship of
the 1790s and and the heavy breathing
and the hysteria right that was fanned
by federalist newspapers against Thomas
Jefferson in a way that performed a
great service for him because when he
finally did win in the election of 1800
you know he had a pretty low bar I mean
all I had to do was was was was not cast
the Bible into a bonfire right you know
not wheedle that the children had to
sing heretical hymns that's funny that
that to me sounds like kind of where
we're at with a consensus like you guys
keep screaming he's Hitler and then
every time he doesn't do Hitler things
he starts looking pretty I think that's
that something to consider absolutely
all right so the election
1800 is a really interesting little
footnote of history why is that well
there's a tie
essentially John John Adams loses you
know that much is clear
but Thomas Jefferson and his running
mate New Yorker Aaron Burr receive an
equal number of electoral votes and you
know one thing to take note of is the
Constitution was written before parties
existed and parties weren't really
anticipated in fact most people thought
that it would be difficult to identify a
person for president that every state
would try and would be you know putting
forward their own favorite son and and
and so to essentially have a filtering
mechanism that would bring forward
people of truly national character the
states were required to vote for at
least one person who wasn't a native of
that state mm-hmm that's why the
electors have two votes and and and so
you know Jefferson's on this ticket with
Aaron Burr the way it's supposed to
happen is the Republicans you know
should be coordinated on enough so that
somebody is designated to toss away his
vote for Aaron Burr and instead vote for
someone else vote for George Washington
right whomever right it didn't matter
right yeah Daffy Daffy Duck yeah but
instead they're so disciplined and that
they all vote for the two people they're
pledged to vote for and the result is a
tie and that means that the House of
Representatives gets to decide you know
who will be the next president the
problem is the House of Representatives
that is seated at the time is the House
of Representatives it was elected in
1798 so the House of Representatives is
controlled by the Federalist Party
so the Federalists have to choose which
which Jeffersonian douwe least you know
want right or maybe can we manipulate or
or whatever it is and and and so Aaron
Burr you know did not make it clear that
he understood that his role was to be
vice president and he did not make it
clear that if he was selected he would
not serve and there was a movement among
many Federalists who of course right all
throughout the 1790s it was you know bad
thing after bad thing after bad thing
being said about Thomas Jefferson uh-huh
yeah I mean he was made
this monster so many thought that
ehrenberg you know what if we support
him
maybe he could be our guy right he'll
owe us and when you say he didn't make
it clear meaning did he suddenly feel
that he should be the one like really
was that well I think I think Aaron Burr
thought that the rules you know in his
defense the rules of the Constitution
were the rules of the Constitution and
if the decision was up to the House of
Representatives then then it wasn't
right for him to step forward and try to
intervene okay you know I I mean I think
that's that's a fair enough thing to say
but but by the same token everybody
understood that that when people cast
their ballots Aaron Burr was intended to
be the vice president that this was an
election between Thomas Jefferson and
John Adams
but now the election of 1800 was over it
was the election of 1801 right and and
and throughout February there's tie vote
after tie vote split decision after
split decision in part because members
of Congress are not voting as
individuals but they're voting as state
delegations so each state delegation
gets one vote and that gives actually
tremendous power to the state of
Delaware's congressmen because he is a a
one man delegation his name is James
Baird and and this is where it's like
it's you can't make a better ending to a
movie all right who should swoop in and
and try to you know tilt things so that
the winner of this contest is Thomas
Jefferson it was Alexander Hamilton Wow
all right so Jefferson's house Eider
Hamilton rights rights to a number of
members of Congress including James
Baird of Delaware and essentially his
argument is this if we support burr
we're gonna own Burr and we're gonna be
held responsible for all the mistakes
that Burr makes whether we could control
him or not all right but if we support
Jefferson our hands will remain without
stain and he said one thing else one
thing more he said that Burr was a man
well he said Jefferson was a man who had
principles with with which he disagreed
was a man who had no principles
whatsoever Wow
okay that's powerful it's powerful but
you know Jefferson owed his presidency
essentially to the intervention of
Alexander Hamilton so let's talk about
the presidency a little bit because for
as much as I love the guy I don't think
a lot of people know that much about the
presidency itself it's more about the
founding and so sure everything else
we've been talking about what do we need
to know about his presidency well I
would say this I would say so the
presidency started late then right
and my understanding is correctly
because because the votes went into
February it didn't actually because you
know it was during the administration of
Franklin Roosevelt that the Constitution
changed the inaugural date traditionally
the the 4th of March was when the
president got an augury okay so okay in
just the nick of time Jefferson was
selected and the 4th of March 1801
Jefferson stood in front of the the
House and the Senate and he read his
inaugural address and you know I mean
it's kind of a remarkable inaugural
address the line that that most people
focus on was one that sounded very
soothing and conciliatory Jefferson said
you know we're all Federalists were all
Republicans I think really what he meant
was we all believed in federalism and we
all believed that we should be able ik
but the that statement was was a
statement about unity and and how we
really should come together but but for
me one of the most notable quotes of the
speech is the word Jefferson he summed
up all the great advantages that America
enjoyed you know we have a great people
we have large quantity of land amazing
resources and he asked you know what
remains too close the circle of our
felicities and he said one thing more my
fellow citizens a wise and frugal
government which will restrain men from
injuring one another but while otherwise
leave men free to their own pursuits of
Industry and improvement and will not
take from the mouths of labor the bread
it has earned this he said is the sum of
good government
so I mean Jefferson is really not really
good a lot of good he's the last
president to promise to do less than his
predecessor
so in effect he was saying we will not
grow the federal government if you
earned it you keep it right and we're
gonna keep you safe but that's pretty
much it I mean it's it's a beautiful
thing I mean it's really consistent with
what you know he wrote and what the
Continental Congress ratified in the
Declaration of Independence you know I
mean if the purpose of government is to
protect individual rights that adds up
to it's to stop people from injuring one
another yeah
and and to otherwise leave him alone now
in in practice I have to you know des -
sure well you know in some ways there's
a lot of success Jefferson repeals all
internal taxes so one of the the big
controversies in the 1790s was Hamilton
as secretary of the Treasury called for
and succeeded in levying a whiskey tax
which you know led to this uprising in
in central and western Pennsylvania in
the middle of the 1790s so Jefferson he
realized the among other things that
these taxes were really expensive to
collect any question Hamilton's motives
he thought that Hamilton in a way was
looking to employ tax collectors and
establish a network of supporters and
also you know to bring people and in
more remote parts of the United States
sort of under the boot of the federal
government to make them feel the power
and and to develop habits of obedience
to the federal government interesting so
these are saw by taxing whiskey in
Pennsylvania you could get the people
that are a little more west to go man
that thing's powerful we got to watch
out well whiskey whiskey essentially for
them was their their substitute for hard
currency yeah you know a lot of them
grew grew corn and you know other oats
that could that could be turned into
whiskey it's not that they all consumed
the whiskey but they could barter with
it right I mean there's a lot of corn in
the bottle of whiskey and the bottle of
whiskey is is not gonna rot over time
it's gonna get better with age so it's
really you know good form of alternative
currency and you know but to pay this
tax you're supposed to pay in hard money
which they didn't have and if you didn't
pay you had to you know go to court in
Philadelphia which could take you away
from your farm for months at a time I
mean there was a lot that was wrong with
this legislation was that also partly
I'm Alton just trying to stick it to
Jefferson it's like we know Jefferson
doesn't want the federal government to
grow we know he doesn't want to raise
taxes so we're gonna try to jam this
thing through I think it was Hamilton's
way of spreading out the burden of
funding the federal government I mean
Hamilton envisioned a federal government
that would take on all sorts of
responsibilities that weren't explicitly
delegated to it in the Constitution and
one of those was assuming the the
Revolutionary War debts of the states so
the states owed a lot of money during
the Revolution they they owed some money
to foreign creditors but the bulk of it
they owed to their own soldiers right
you wouldn't receive actual payment you
know if you were a soldier fighting for
say Massachusetts instead you would
receive an IOU a bond note and problem
was your family couldn't eat that they
needed real money and so there were
investors who would you know buy those
for pennies on the dollar because who
knows if this promise which wouldn't
come true for another ten years who
knows if that government that made that
promise would even exist in ten years we
could lose the revolution yeah and and
who knows that the the face value would
really be all that meaningful given the
high level of inflation that was taking
place during the revolution so people
stuck their necks out they took some
risks and they bought up this stuff at
pennies on the dollar and then you know
those investors tended to bundle
together these these promissory notes
and sell them to even larger more
important investors and I think what
Hamilton was was onto was the fact that
if the states owed this money to those
powerful investors those powerful
investors would have sort of a real
interest in seeing the financial success
of those states but if instead the new
national government assumed to those
debts and owed that money to these rich
and important people that these rich and
important people these powerful people
would have a vested interest in seeing
the national government have a more
robust capacity to tax think about that
all right HAMP I mean Hamilton's a ninja
right I mean he comes up with this with
a scheme that
makes it in the interest of the most
well-off people in America to see higher
taxes but wouldn't it be even better if
those taxes were dispersed yeah and not
imposed upon the people who lived along
the coastline right through tariffs and
things but instead through these excise
task taxes like the one on whiskey so
Hamilton and Jefferson basically must
have been at loggerheads the entire time
right yeah I mean you know there's one
description where Jefferson writes that
they were like you know to uh to to Cox
about to fight right you know like this
this was really a tense time yeah and in
a difficult moment but that's all behind
us in in 1801 and you know Jefferson is
is going to slim down the federal
government he's going to slash the
federal work force in part because he
repeals these taxes and he could let go
of all these tax collectors you know
it's so funny to think back on this it's
like he was the third President of the
United States and he was talking about
slimming down the government he went
people talk about it now like you know
cut some government you know cut some
pork cut some regulator's whatever the
awesome thing is it's not just talk I
mean during the course of Jefferson's
presidency a presidency where we have a
really big splurge by the way you know
when we decide to for 15 million dollars
double the size of the United States by
purchasing Louisiana even with the
purchase of Louisiana during the course
of Jefferson's presidency he pays down
one-third of the national debt that's a
significant achievement yeah what else
we need to know about his presidency
well you know maybe like a lot of
presidents the first term it seems
really good the second term maybe not so
much I mean one of the things that that
Jefferson thought Louisiana might do
right is provide us with a land moat
that like the Atlantic Ocean would
insulate us from the problems of Europe
right I think it's it's fundamentally
unfair to say that Jefferson wanted us
to be more like France
I think Jefferson wanted us to to be as
removed from the problems of Europe as
possible in fact he wrote that if France
you know is able to maintain possession
of Louisiana
you know this vast territory immediately
to our west it will become our
and habitual enemy meds the United
States will have to marry itself to the
British fleet so buying Louisiana in a
way helps America to maintain its
diplomatic neutrality and avoid you know
the the problems of European warfare and
remember of course the France is in
Louisiana to our West Britain is still
in Canada to our north and those two
nations being at war it's almost like a
law of physics you know during the time
period what was the cell job for the
Louisiana Purchase like um you know it's
interesting because it wasn't a tough
sell at all you know the news arrived in
the United States that this treaty had
been negotiated by James Monroe and by
robert Livingston you know with Napoleon
in France the news arrived on July 4th
1803 so great timing right and that we
could double the size of our country
without firing a single shot and we're a
nation that we double in population
every 20 years so I mean this really
provides the United States with some
breathing room with some room to grow
and and it really seems to solve a lot
of problems there's a problem that
people aren't talking about but that
Jefferson's thinking about that I think
is really revealing and really
instructive and it brings us maybe to
another moment where Jefferson
compromises you know Jefferson the
strict constructionist where in the
Constitution does the national
government have the power to acquire new
Terry yeah I was actually gonna get
there you know I mean it's it's not
there and and Jefferson
you know his first impulse is to do what
a strict constructionist would do if he
wanted you know to have more power under
the Constitution he drafted a
constitutional amendment that would have
explicitly authorized the purchase of
Louisiana so he was gonna try to do it
the right way he was gonna do the right
way so to speak yeah he was gonna try
but you know almost like one of those
remember the cartoons like Tom and Jerry
and you know they'd be like if whenever
anyone has a an ethical dilemma a little
cartoon angel yeah there are little
cards of devil right yeah well well the
cartoon devil / Jefferson's shoulder was
James Madison and on the other shoulder
there was another cartoon devil
Albert Gallatin is Treasury secretary
they urged him they said look this is
just you're playing with fire here and
this deal is
almost too good to be true if we send
this out this amendment out for
ratification what if we don't get the
three-quarters of states necessary what
if it takes too long
what if Napoleon gets cold feet what if
he pulls out of the deal you know they
said just let the Senate approve the
treaty let the House of Representatives
appropriate the funds and and and and
just sign this just make this happen and
did he just he just accepted that
recommendation from them he did I mean
you know there was a risk that he
understood and essentially asserting
that this was an implied power of the
Constitution right because I would
imagine his base at the time that
probably really loved him for all the
reason right we're talking about here
they might have been kind of pissed like
wait a minute wait a minute aren't you
the guy that's not supposed to expand
power sadly I David I think you're
giving too much credit to people right I
mean this is maybe a an early
illustration of the fact that you know
what when your guys in power maybe maybe
you're not so good about making sure
that he follows all the rules and and if
you liked the the proposal if you like
the the public policy that he's pursuing
in this case doubling the size of the
country peacefully then then you're not
going to be too critical about how it's
accomplished and which is what we see
now every day right every political
issue out there any any other major
accomplishments and the in the second
term well you know I mean there are
accomplishments throughout but I think
they're the major controversy in the
second term you know deals with the fact
that for all for all the benefits that
came to the United States through the
purchase of Louisiana sadly one of them
wasn't insulating us from the problems
of Europe and you know Britain and
France continued to be at war and they
were harassing our ships on the high
seas and you know the British especially
were you know threatening our commercial
vessels as well as our naval vessels and
you know more and more people were
clamoring for war and and Jefferson and
Madison - they weren't pacifists but
they understood
that it was a really where it was a
really rare war mm-hmm that made a
country more free and in Madison even
wrote in 1791 you know that of all the
enemies of true liberty wars the most to
be feared because it shows all these
seeds that compromise liberty
you know compromises to civil liberties
debts taxes standing armies and that's
if you win right so so Jefferson wants
to try to avoid a war with with Britain
or with France and and he comes up with
the idea of having a general trade
embargo so we're not gonna put our ships
out at risk we're not going to allow our
commercial vessels to trade with the
rest of the world we're gonna keep them
home safe in our own ports will produce
for ourselves we'll manufacture for
ourselves and and this will provide us
with diplomatic leverage that is going
to bring you know Great Britain and
France to their knees as pain once wrote
you know Europe will need America as
long as Europe needs to eat and indeed
you know bread prices rose but but it
did not have the immediate effect that
Jefferson hoped for
yeah so how did his presidency end
basically you know I mean I think it
ends in in a mixed way the embargo
stretches from 1807 to 1809 one of
Jefferson's last acts is signing the
bill that repeals it Madison is going to
institute sort of a watered-down embargo
series of laws called the
non-intercourse acts but but the fact
that this embargo as onerous and
unpopular as it is in certain parts of
America and as popular it's unpopular
everywhere I mean you know Salem
Massachusetts was the second most
important port in Massachusetts in a
second only to Boston it was one of
America's largest cities at the time and
there are all these dock workers all
these sailors were out of work their
soup kitchens their bread lines and then
the South right where you have you know
large farms or plain
tations that are producing agriculture
for export there there you know produce
is is sitting in warehouses rotting huh
and yet despite all that Jefferson and
Madison retain enough support so that
Madison in the election of 1800
Jefferson's hand-picked successor is
going to handily defeat his Federalist
opponent Wow
so the later years after the presidency
in terms of public life what was he
doing I mean I think Jefferson helps to
establish the precedent that retired
presidents kind of keep their nose down
and don't interfere and in the news he
really had a great friend in the new
President James Madison and and in terms
of their private correspondence there
they're still you know communicating
with one another Madison will sometimes
ask for advice Jefferson will sometimes
you know respond to those requests by
giving it but but by and large Jefferson
is going to turn his attention to new
projects and and perhaps you know this
is what you think about as you get on in
years and and become retired you start
thinking about the future in the future
isn't you right the future is the next
generation and so Jefferson is going to
devote the waning years of his life to
the creation of a new University one
that he hopes will be better than the
the old College of William and Mary one
that will provide a temptation to the
use of other states to come and drink of
the cup of knowledge with us it's a
great quote yeah and that's the
University of Virginia which you know
was established in 1819 by the state
legislature and Monticello is only what
does five miles away so right there not
to tell if he was building that
throughout his presidency or when did
that I want to start Monticello is uh is
one of those projects that never ends
yeah I mean you know Jefferson all these
guys had that project right they always
had these things that it was like over
the course of 40 years yeah still being
built I I suppose that's true I mean you
know Jefferson there was people
sometimes refer to Monticello one and
Monticello two so you know right around
the time that Jefferson got married
they began the process of building
Monticello one and you know there
Jefferson had the the drawings the
designs his designs he designed it he
designed it right but then you know he
always learned he spent his lifetime
learning and he came up with new ideas
and better ideas and he revised his plan
so they ended up having to pull down
part of what had already been built and
then reconstructing some and and and you
know building more yeah so by this point
I think it's fair to say that the the
house itself the the walls are all there
right and and the interior work maybe is
mostly done but you know the work on on
this you know plantation Monticello it
continues I mean it continues not just
for Thomas Jefferson but of course right
for his enslaved workforce and the issue
of slavery is one that by the time he
reaches retirement it's really sad right
I mean here's a guy who always has a
plan who always seems to have the energy
and the will right to make the world a
better place and by the eighteen tens
and teens you have slavery becoming a
much more divisive national issue you
have an increasing polarization between
the North and the South in part because
you know one one unmentioned achievement
of Jefferson's presidency is that at the
earliest constitutionally allowable
moment Jefferson is able to sign into
law a bill that ends the international
slave trade so you could no longer
legally bring people from Africa as
slaves to the United States and and
that's possible in part because not only
do you have growing anti-slavery
sentiment in the north but southern
planters who already own slaves in a way
this is like an anti-competitive law for
them you know upstarts who want to get
new land and grow cotton
now the slaves that are already owned
are gonna be more valuable because
limits the supply yeah but but the
cotton boom has been explained
and there's more westward expansion and
people you know are moving on the other
side of the Mississippi River in
Missouri right wants to be admitted to
the Union as a state that allows slavery
and the north is opposed to this by and
large and and you know this increasing
polarization it sucks in Thomas
Jefferson as well and I think he
increasingly sees the the United States
as being a nation that's divided between
the north and the south so what do we
know about his last writings or thoughts
about slavery well you know there are a
number of younger people who are
endeavoring to do you know pretty cool
things right there's a guy named Edward
Coles who is a well-off Virginian who
has this sincere kind of life commitment
to free his slaves and and so what he
does is he moves from Virginia with all
these people who he legally owned to
Ohio right and there he divvies up the
land and he makes sure that they get
education and training and that they
could you know survive and succeed on
their own so at that point you could
take your slaves over state lines and
then you those laws would be applicable
well you could you could and remember I
mean the reason he's taking them to Ohio
is is that Ohio Jefferson's ordinance of
1785 failed by one vote but the
compromise was the Northwest Ordinance
of 1787 and that drew the line at the
Ohio River so the land north of that
would prohibit slavery so coles is
intentionally taking these these
african-americans to a place where
slavery was not going to be on the table
and he liberate some and he writes to
jefferson he says what do you think of
my idea and jefferson you know
essentially responds i think it's great
i hope you succeed and i will pray for
you but at my age prayers are pretty
much all that i can offer
hmm that's all that I've got left so
it's a shame because again Jefferson at
this point deeply encumbered by debt
you know deeply involved as as the at
least paper owner of slaves I mean again
his creditors
you know our in some ways the possessors
of these people who are essentially held
hostage at Monticello I mean it's really
poignant and it's really sad and you
know some people call Jefferson a
hypocrite I don't think that's quite the
right word because you know Jefferson
did engage in actions designed to blunt
the growth of slavery and Jefferson more
than any office holder of his generation
you know took measures and made
proposals to curb slavery see and that's
also why I find him to be so fascinating
because of course by our standards now
we would all be abolitionists sure we
would all be screaming of course slavery
should be illegal and we should all have
equal rights and all that but there's
also a realism of being a person of your
time right and it seems that in most
cases where he had the opportunity to do
something he did actually do something
so to judge him from our perspective now
I just when I hear people do it and this
goes with many historic surges it just
seems it's like a sort of paper tiger to
me I mean in some ways one of the
critiques that Federalists levied
against Jefferson was that one which is
kind of tickles me he said you know he's
much more fit to be a college professor
than a man of state a man of action a
man of consequence and I and I totally
get you know the the insult towards
college professors I I totally get it
but but I would say that there's
something fundamentally flawed about
this notion that Thomas Jefferson is
this pie-in-the-sky theorist I mean he
really is a pragmatist he really I mean
he's a man of vision and he's a man of
principle but he's also a man who
believes that he that you know what we
can get done we should get done and just
as he compromises on the issue of
slavery and essentially puts it on the
back burner in the 1790s to try to you
know wrestle back control from the
Federalists who he thought were counter
revolutionaries endangering the freedom
of white Americans in in his retirement
removed from power looking at what he
could possibly do and what he just
couldn't possibly do the University of
Virginia was a was by no means a
foregone conclusion and by no means was
it an easy sell you know for
State Legislature to get them to fund
this with with with the public's money
but but it was doable it was within
reach and and doing something to end
slavery was was not within reach and so
you know in a way it's kind of a shame
but Jefferson would try to marshal
support for this new university in
Virginia by pointing to the Missouri
crisis and exploiting the the increased
tensions between the north and the south
and he'd say to people in Virginia do we
really want to be sending our sons to
these seminaries in the north to Harvard
and Yale and Princeton where they're
gonna be contaminated with all these
northern ideas wouldn't it be better to
keep them here wouldn't it be better to
bring northerners to us and and to let
them you know see see our way of life
and our way of thinking now to others he
says that the Missouri crisis is you
know a mere ripple on the sea of Liberty
but within Virginia I think he really
tries to leverage this this moment of
sectional tension to help you know move
his proposals for the University of
Virginia across the finish line and it
clearly worked it worked yeah anything
else we need to know about the the right
I mean he died at Monticello right well
yeah I mean he died on the 4th of July
1826
and and I mean this guy had something
with timing huh
yeah I mean he it was a very timely
demise right I mean Thomas Jefferson in
the last few months of his life you know
started to express a wish to live to see
the the 50th anniversary of American
independence the 4th of July 1826 and
you know as the the weeks and then the
days passed it became increasingly
doubtful that that goal would be
achieved you know he was on his deathbed
by the beginning of the month there were
a couple of people who were attending to
him there was his his grandson Thomas
Jefferson Randolph there was this grand
son-in-law a West Point dropout named
Nicholas Petrus
and his doctor a professor of medicine
at the University of Virginia dr. Riley
dunglison and Jefferson was fading in
and out of
justice how old was he at the time he's
83 years old so a good long life yeah
right but but on the night of the the
first he wakes up and he asks is it the
fourth right and they they disappoint
him they not yet right the night of the
second he asked this time with a weaker
voice is it the fourth and again the
answer is no and around 11 p.m. on July
3rd 1826 and it seemed like he could go
at any moment his eyes just sort of
split open and he asked is it the 4th
and Nicholas trist who apparently hadn't
had enough time at her West Point's
honor code lies to Thomas Jefferson and
he nods his head he says yes it is it
couldn't bear to let him down and and a
lot of historians seem to have it wrong
they say that those were Jefferson's
last words but if you look at the notes
of dr. Rob Lee dunglison according to
his account he then offers Jefferson
another dose of medication and Jefferson
having been assured that the 4th of July
had already arrived says to dr. Douglas
in nothing more so it'd be a terrible
story if right then right there until I
third Jefferson died but the the good
news is he lived until noon the next day
he died 50 years to the hour after the
ratification of the Declaration of
Independence and if that's not
incredible enough right up in Braintree
Massachusetts John Adams is on his
deathbed and and his last words around
5:00 p.m. are has no idea what's
happened down in Virginia his last words
are Thomas Jefferson survives so on one
level I'd like to think that Jefferson
at that moment you know being carried
upward on the wings of angels as
laughing his butt off right because once
again he's proven John Adams wrong but
I'd like to think too that on another
level John Adams was right that you know
Jefferson does survive his ideas survive
the ideas of the revolutionary
generation survive all right they're
always going to be contested and we're
always gonna have to figure out how how
we make them real in our ever-changing
world but there's something timeless
about those ideas and I think that you
know John Adams and James Madison
and in George Washington and certainly
Thomas Jefferson enduringly made a mark
on the face of the world in favor of
freedom Rob McDonald you know how to end
an interview that's how you do it it was
a pleasure talking to you it was great
this is what it was all about I'm so
glad that we kicked off presidents week
doing this because it just it gets into
all of the richness of their their
perfections and imperfections and why
it's applicable today and all that good
stuff so we are gonna link to Rob's book
right down below it's confounding father
Thomas Jefferson's image in his own time
the Amazon link will be right down below
and we've got four more days of
Presidents week all week this week
[Music]
you
[Music]